children born to single parents are far  more likely to have behavior problems  far more likely to have academic  problems far more likely to drop out of  school far more likely to get expelled  far more likely to end up in prison far  more likely to end up on drugs far more  likely to end up homeless far more  likely to fall victim to violent crime  on and on and on it is extremely bad for  children and for society to abandon  marriage that's just the fact but as is  so often the case what is bad for kids  and bad for the culture is really good  for the Democrats you know they are the  Democrat Party is a it's a vulture you  know it feasts on the carcass of uh  decaying civilizations